hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander funny vines compilation of
all time don't [ __ ] laugh let's do
this
my husband freaked out eggs into the
yard and they're like it wasn't even hot
and I think you have been chopped this
i'ma walk before
have you ever added dreams that that you
um you add you do what you could you do
you it you want you you could do so you
you'll do you could use you want you
want to earn affluence me and my own
person I'm a strong black woman
you better get my fix now that's cool
just meet Alex hanging out solo no speed
up guys Oh put your finger on the screen
right here and wiggle it up and down
stop is my room here
ah man kids Bobby like my mommy my mommy
won't let me have cake it till I eat my
broccoli yeah
stop leaving your banana in my face
something you wanted but just kidding I
got it Oh fat people the brownies on the
Dan Oh
oh my god doesn't break his neck
to talk to a customer
please press1 guy's story
um I'm basically just teaching eyes at a
chrome hair
there it makes I want you better and it
might use a hundred dollars aren't you
serious thank you but so when I see what
I want to eat what do you want
it's not that simple what do you want
just give me three catch
you know what happens the kids that
don't put on the seat belt um face
selfie workouts when you pitch me
everyone you know that all the neighbors
love me hey how much a big payment have
you ever had those days when you're here
Kylie what are you doing Oh
Jenny Patel is mom for you went to a
party last night yes mom we should add
booty bouncing is now over the bag the
bag first let me take a selfie
Bailey can I have my skittles back come
on those are mine Hey
hands up BAE
Oh is he being in our bezel why are
these ladies doing the duck fish selfie
no stop it goes black
no makeup go to look back at it look
back at it look back yeah gonna look
back grab it on the graph medics do you
want to do this oh man ochio crew [ __ ]
thought I told you if you're playing a
game you should hold you a man shot my
[ __ ] game hey I think I'm gonna buy
some Crocs
heat work the whole
girls have a vagina I have a penis for
you but Johnny not gonna make this quick
um our discussion tell me a part of the
body that begins with the letter T
did you let a call I genuinely enjoy
that I was like you know what this is
even even when I'm not laughing
hysterically I'm not bored I thought it
was really entertaining that it was more
of like those funny videos you found on
YouTube but like you're in the morning
then like actually you bynars doing
buying things I don't know I think that
was fun to watch
what kind of description is that era you
know when the miners are just like girls
me like and I do something it just kind
of gets old but these are all genuinely
funny they were genuinely funny vines I
fart I could I broke so hard I had a
couple of favorite ones are the one I
really liked was when the guy was
sleeping in the car and oh yeah come on
baby got the truck is coming up I've
seen I've seen that before but with like
a mom before I don't know that's like
gonna look and I love with the little
black girl with her hair was tied up and
it just I was wondering long yeah yeah I
was like what wife is so foot inches
cubed hey Mike answer me yaoi
they never randomly meow-meow reaction
listen if you're new to the channel you
cannot subscribe to the real rejects
salamander sally has a channel do it's a
fun fun fun [ __ ] channel and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope do you periscope
I have it you should use it sometime I
should periscope and make sure your
cleavage is showing you'll get a lot
more followers Sally
Joshua Chia
yo Ryan you got some amazeballs Vince
I've been watching you since you had
50,000 subs the girl I've been watching
him since he had like one yeah yeah girl
do you know what else is amazeballs pie
but other than that is shoutout okay
I didn't have enough dots and [ __ ] see
is it to really get the punchline can my
channel get a shout-out twisted TV okay
is it actually sick and twisted let's
see here let's see what you uploaded you
look like my cousin Jordan my nerdy
cousin Jordan my nerdy Asian cousin
Jordan I don't know exactly what your
channel consists of but let me tell you
man
from one fat guy to a nerd here's what I
can tell you it's all about personality
this nerd thing going on you ain't gonna
get any poonanny warning you just so
much stuff would you date him he have
knowledge that's important did you
answer the question I mean he looks like
he's in middle school I considered
dating him ever in middle school yeah
you would consider dating I was not a
very popular girl in middle school oh I
was but I mean everybody knows dude that
not really good Asians are known to have
small penises so you gotta make up for
that by looking hot in the face about
penises yeah you weren't out there yet I
mean obviously I knew they existed but
not everything about vagina since I
wasn't one haven't done a product
placement joke in a while vaginas